and the man on the mound the
right-hander aaron sanchez
for sanchez this will be start number
four comes in all in one 2.45 era
so now miguel rojas to the plate for
miami and at 3 16.
five doubles a triple he's yet to homer
this year he's knocked in six
now the pitch to rojas and that hits him
right in this right in the back
and you could hear him kind of shout and
now he's looking out at sanchez and
sanchez comes down off the mound and
he's looking at
rojas they're talking to each other the
umpire goes out
jim wolfe to try and make sure that they
don't go after each other here
so right out of the chute the marlins
have a golden opportunity here in the
first inning jesus aguilar coming up
sanchez pitching casalli catching and
there's a swing of the bouncer right
back to sanchez he's got it the second
one
the stellar the first two a double play
a one-hopper right back to sanchez
over to third base goes jazz chisholm
now an rbi shot for the marlins leading
rbi man adam duvall he's knocked in 14
runs this season
now the 2-0 pitch swing there's a high
drive into
left center field pretty deep back into
his right slater onto the warning track
and near the wall he reaches up to make
the catch
and the side is retired that was back in
the vicinity of the 399 marker out there
which is kind of a graveyard for home
run hitters
duvall is retired and after a promising
beginning
the mornings come up empty we go to the
last of the first inning
and the man on the mound the lefty
making his second start of the season
his second against the giants dan
castano castano batting ninth
two men on two men out and here comes
daryn ruff
driven to left and it's over the head of
dickerson
coming in to score is just got a double
longoria the third the stremski scoring
and the giants have a run here in the
first
and a one nothing lead and here is kurt
casalli to try and drive some more
people in
one and one to kurt casalli who has
power he's big and strong
now the 1-1 pitch line drive base hit
and it's kicked by dickerson and that's
gonna allow ruff to score
three nothing now that's a first
that is a first if i didn't know better
i think that then bunny was fake
so you know what they do after easter
they go to ball games we just found that
out
they got a rabbit yep and it's not a
small one either
that's a big fella let him run
here's flores castano the 6'3 234
pounder
looks in the 1-2 pitch bounce right back
to the pitcher castano has it
he'll flip the first base aguilar gets
over to take the throw and
that's all for the giants in the second
so this time castano can get that third
out
and we'll head to the third giants
and up comes adam duvall the former
janitors really
had an excellent career he was he was
only a giant briefly
was drafted by the giants developed by
them had great minor league numbers for
the giants but
was traded away 2-2 is
strike three called he got him with the
changeup duvall can't believe it
two down second strikeout for sanchez
casalli out of vanderbilt like his
teammate mikey ostremski
they are two of 11 vanderbilt commodores
who are on opening day major league
rosters here in 2021 vandy has more
players open day rosters than any other
college
three and two and there's a called
strike three
they've just clipped the inside corner
well it's three nothing but maybe some
concern
is evan longoria is out of the game
and the giants have moved a bunch of
people around flores goes from first
to third rough goes from left to first
and dickerson comes into the game
welcome back there is alex the greatest
watch this
the owners or the parents or whatever
you want to call want a ball and
and alex almost alex is he
don't want any part of this anymore yaz
has ripped a double into the gap in
right center and hit a hard ground ball
to second
2-2 to mikey strips a little tap right
in front of the plate wallach is on it
quickly
throws the first and they get the out
that ends the inning
so the giants get a man to second but
leave him there no runs one hit
one error one stranded will go to the
sixth very exciting moment here and we
are hoping that aaron sanchez is fine
and i'm assuming he is he looked great
on the mound five scoreless innings but
now in the six he gives way to
a young right-hander making his major
league debut he's got
tremendous stuff gregory santos who's
never pitching a game above a ball
and it's been a while even since that
but he's been pitching at the alternate
site has made appearances in big league
spring training games santos ready to go
on the mound for the giants
as now we're going to get a pinch hitter
for the marlins and sierra's gonna hit
for castano so this knight's going to be
over as well
here's the 3-2 pitch slider struck him
out looking
and then cassalli tosses that ball over
to the giants dugout
to be put in a safe place as a memento
for
gregory santos he strikes out the first
batter that he
faces in the big leagues chisholm is
single in the first a fly ball left in
the third
o2 pitch he struck him out swinging
on a mighty cut by jazz chibsum on a
really nasty slide of the broke down and
then and well
out of the strike zone we got some word
on why evan longoria
left the game which and it's not good
but it
also doesn't sound like it's terrible
but
one of those things a little too early
to tell whether it's
terrible or not tight left hamstring so
not
strained or pulled just tight and i
think on a cold night
it's not that surprising that maybe
you'd have some muscle tightness
and when it's a hamstring you got to be
really careful so
you can see why the giants pulled him
from the game all right here we go 9th
inning
jake mcgee who has served very ably as
the giants closer this year
jake mcgee out of the bullpen
and here is miguel rojas
got him and that's the ball game mcgee
strikes out the side and casalli what
does he do he catches another shutout
that's five in a row for the giants
backup catcher
so congratulations well that's
a remarkable accomplishment but it gives
you an idea of the kind of confidence
that this giant staff has
in casali so for the giants they do all
the damage in the first inning
and it was kosali who had really the
biggest hit of the game we knocked in
two runs so
on curt casale night giants take the
opener here against the marlins